ya he hablado de la saga ninja gaiden en
el canal y si algún afortunado día sale
el tan esperado ninja gaiden 4
eventualmente lo seguiré haciendo y hoy
nos toca hablar del videojuego que
comenzó una cirugía moderna de ninja
gaiden que también se llama ninja gaiden
considerado uno de los juegos más
difíciles de los últimos tiempos y el
videojuego que revivió la saga ninja
gaiden y le dio un nuevo tono
convirtiéndola en uno de los mejores
exponentes del hack and slash ninja
gaiden para la xbox original siempre
será recordado como aquel juego donde el
alma te tocaba los huevos y te dejaban
los dedos en los controles para poder
derrotarla a ella y superar todos los
demás retos de este desafiante juego
quería hacer el vídeo de 30 curiosidades
como ya lo he hecho con sus anteriores
pero la verdad es que ninja gaiden uno
no tiene tantas curiosidades como
pensaba es decir si encontráis bastantes
curiosidades pero no así que mediara
labor de investigar bastante para
encontrar estas 10 curiosidades que
espero te resulten interesantes así que
vamos a ver 10 curiosidades secretos y
detalles de ninja gaiden
ninja gaiden al igual que los demás
juegos de la saga tuvo diferentes
versiones por diferencia de los demás
títulos ninja gaiden no tuvo una ni dos
sino tres versiones extra siendo estas
la versión sigma para playstation
la versión sigma plus para playstation
vita y la más conocida la versión black
la versión black del juego introdujo
mucho contenido el juego base como armas
más varias de enemigos el modo misión y
todo el contenido de 2d lc pero lo más
destacado que introdujo el ninja gaiden
black fue su dificultad maestro ninja
que antes no existía siendo la versión
black el primer juego en introducir
dicha dificultad y el juego que
comenzaría con la tradición de
introducir el modo maestro ninja a todos
los demás juegos logrando además ser
catalogado como uno de los modos de
dificultad más desafiantes
cuando completas el juego en dificultad
normal difícil o muy difícil ganar a
ciertas recompensas a modo de
felicitación por completar el juego en
dichas dificultades pero curiosamente
cuando completan el juego en la mayor
dificultad haciendo este el modo maestro
ninja al terminar no ganarás ni
desbloquearás absolutamente nada ni un
traje ni un arma ni siquiera mensaje de
consolación por las 800 mil veces que
diste haber muerto el maestro ninja esto
es debido a que tomonobu itagaki el
creador del juego pensó que el modo
maestro ninja iba a ser tan difícil que
probablemente nadie sería capaz de
completarlo así que no se molestó en
añadir ninguna recompensa como mencioné
antes el juego tiene una versión
especial llamada ninja gaiden sigma plus
que fue creada para el playstation vita
esta versión del juego tiene ciertos
añadidos como nuevos trajes o accesorios
que podría equipar le arribó a rachel
para darles ciertos aumentos en sus
habilidades pero lo más curioso en ninja
gaiden sigma plus es el hecho de que se
creó una dificultad fácil exclusivamente
para esta versión a este modo de
dificultad ha salido el nombre de modo
héroe y fue la primera vez en la que un
juego de ninja gaiden tuvo una
dificultad fácil para jugadores más
casuales
al igual que como mencioné en mi vídeo
de ninja gaiden 2 este juego también
tiene un interés que referencia a xbox
ya que aquí también podemos encontrar
una figura con la forma del tan
característico logo de las primeras
consolas de xbox les interactuamos con
el la salud de río y sus habilidades se
verán restauradas
hay una curiosa manera de conseguir
esencia amarilla infinita para comprar
objetos o mejorar tus armas es bastante
sencillo después de la primera batalla
con alma cuando los militares comienzan
a barrer la zona habrá un lugar en
específico donde los enemigos van a
estar cada vez que tú aparezcas así que
te puedes aprovechar de esto solo tienes
que entrar en dicha área acabar con los
enemigos salir volver a entrar y repetir
el proceso cuántas veces desee hasta
tener tanta esencia amarilla como tú
quieras a pesar de que en el juego
tenemos armas increíbles muy poderosas
la espada de madera que parece ser
inofensiva guarda algunos secretos ya
que primero el arma se puede mejorar
siete veces lo que la convierte en el
arma que más veces se puede mejorar en
toda la saga segundo puede aparecer la
gran cosa pero al ser mejorar en su
totalidad espada de manera que hará un
increíble poder además de la habilidad
de aumentar su daño en un 150% cuando la
salud del río se encuentra muy baja lo
que en conjunto la convierte en el arma
más poderosa de todo el juego
si completamos el juego y además
reunimos todos los escarabajos dorados
repartidos a lo largo de todo el mapa
podremos desbloquear el juego para
arcade en 1998 y el ninja gaiden
original para jugarlos cuantas veces
queramos
la versión black esconde un secreto
bastante curioso ya que después del
lanzamiento de la versión original del
juego hubo muchos jugadores quejándose
de la dificultad del juego diciendo que
era demasiado difícil así que cansados
de tantos lloriqueos y a modo de burla
los creadores del juego incluyeron un
modo de dificultad oculto al cual
llamaron perro ninja para conseguirlo
tenía que morir tres veces seguidas en
el inicio del juego con lo cual el mismo
juego asumiría que es demasiado difícil
para ti y si te preguntaría tres veces
seguidas si eres demasiado joven para
completar el juego y si deseaba
abandonar tu camino como ninja 3 puede
que sí a todo saltar una pequeña escena
oculta en donde hayan muy decepcionada
le habla a un inconsciente río una serie
por 3-6 y aun interview hayabusa
exiliado y
lowell mientras puede ver si algo es
oportuno recordar a quien rompió ver
competente que estuviese en profundidad
esas competencias que tienen y un mes
completo charles witt
la razón por la cual se dice que la
espada del dragón y la espada del dragón
oscuro son gemelas es mucho más
interesante de lo que el juego nos
cuenta según el logro y la mitología de
ninja gaiden se nos cuenta que mucho
mucho tiempo antes de los humanos
existieron varias deidades dentro de las
cuales se destacaban los 13 dragones
sagrados que eran criaturas que usaban
su enorme poder para el bien del mundo
si nuestro dragones quienes
eventualmente crearían a los humanos por
miles de años humanos y dragones con
vivirían pacíficamente siendo los
dragones los protectores de la vida en
la tierra pero esto cambió cuando el
menor de los tres dragones comenzó a
corromperse y a ser poseído por todo el
odio y la maldad que habitaba en la
tierra esto llevó a una inevitable
batalla entre los dos de dragones
restantes contra su hermano lo cual
terminó en la derrota de los dos era
gones mientras el dragón oscuro comenzó
a llevar caos y destrucción a la tierra
los dos dragones pusieron toda su fe en
un guerrero humano a quien le otorgarían
como regalo uno de sus colmillos en
donde pondrían sus almas y su poder
convirtiéndolo en la espada del dragón
con la cual los humanos finalmente
derrotarían al dragón oscuro pero los
demonios que habitaban la tierra al
presenciar su derrota
y el gran poder de la espada del dragón
decidieron crear un arma que igualará o
superará su poder así que con los huesos
de la criatura forjarían la espada del
dragón oscuro es por eso que se les
considera gemelas
ambas espadas fueron creadas a partir de
los dragones sagrados pero una fue
creada por el bien de la humanidad y la
otra para destruirla
llegamos al final de los datos sé que
fueron pocos días a diferencia de los 30
que acostumbro a acceder pero hay pocos
datos que [ __ ] quieres que haga
es una pena que el juego en serio no
tenga más curiosidades ni datos
interesantes siendo el juegazo que es
pero hay chicas en lugares de más datos
curiosos aquí te dejo el vídeo que hice
sobre el ninja gaiden 2 o siempre déjame
tus opiniones en los comentarios y si
quieren que le dedique un vídeo ni
deberían 3 para cerrar la trilogía
hágamelo saber y con gusto me pondré a
trabajar en él la próxima
[Música]